-Hey Natalia, hey Christoph. Ich bins,
Robin. Ich habe zwei Fragen für dich. Die
erste ist: Bevorzugst du es eher eine
Schauspielerin zu sein oder eine
Musikerin?  Und die zweite ist: Woher
bekommst du all die Ideen für deine
Lieder? Ich hoffe, dass du diese Fragen
beantworten wirst und ich wünsche dir
einen schönen Tag.
-Das, was ich am meisten bevorzuge ist
es, ein Gestalter zu sein. Es ist das
einzige, was ich wirklich für den Rest
meines Lebens machen will. Ich will
einfach nur ein kreatives Leben führen.
Ich denke nicht, dass ich nur eine
Schauspielerin sein könnte, weil ich die
Geschichte schreiben will. Ich will nicht
einen Charakter spielen, Ich will mich
selbst spielen. Ich denke, dass ich meine
eigenen Lebenserfahrungen habe, meine
eigenen Gedanken und es wäre eine
Verschwendung immer nur eine Rolle zu
spielen, von der ich mich freistehend
fühlen würde. Deshalb liebe ich es, Lieder
für mich selbst, für andere Leute, für
Filme und Soundtracks zu schreiben. Ich
liebe es, meine eigene Webserie aus
kleinen Filmen zu leiten. Alles, was mich
inspiriert, meine ganzen
Lebenserfahrungen kann ich in eine
Kreation reinpacken und ich denke, dass
ich so lange ich ein kreatives Leben
führen kann wird die Musik, das Filme
drehen, Bücher und Drehbücher
schreiben, was ich im Moment mache,
immer an erster Stelle kommen.
*wisch*